monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le texte
qui nous est présenté aujourd'hui par
notre collègue Vanina paoligajin
s'inscrit dans un contexte où les
conséquences du changement climatique
sur la gestion des forêts sont de plus
en plus perceptibles par l'opinion
publique je ne reviendrai pas sur les
feux de forêts qui ont rythmé les
actualités de notre pays tout au long de
la période estivale mais il est
important de noter que ce texte
s'inscrit sans mauvais de jeux de mots
dans une actualité brûlante en la
matière
des Cévennes aux Bouches-du-Rhône en
passant par la Gironde des feux
importants considérés par la communauté
scientifique comme des mégafeux ont
détruit plus de 11000 hectares de forêt
cet été
au niveau mondial les prévisions de
l'ONU comme du GIEC ne sont guère plus
optimistes
ces incendies ont un impact important
dans la mesure où ils entraînent la
disparition de plusieurs espèces
animales et végétales l'exemple
australien et révélateur les mégafeux de
Bruce de 2020 aurait causé la
disparition de milliards d'animaux
domestiques et sauvages ainsi que 832
espèces différentes
cette proposition qui attrait au régime
des dons octroyés à des communes ou
établissements de public de coopération
intercommunale dans le cas de la gestion
de la forêt s'insère donc dans un moment
décisif elle vise ainsi par un
accroissement des dons à mieux financer
l'entretien de la forêt public qui ne
représente rappelons-le qu'un quart de
la forêt française environ
plusieurs remarques me viennent à la
lecture du dispositif de cette PPL tout
d'abord sur le ciblage il nous paraît
très largement imparfait par rapport
l'ambition développée dans le titre et
dans l'exposé des motifs
de plus le texte vise à faire supporter
le financement de l'action publique par
les dons et non par la puissance
publique je reviendrai plus longuement
après sur les raisons qui me poussent à
penser que ceci n'est pas la bonne
doctrine
enfin la réduction d'impôts et le
véhicule fiscal utilisé mais ce dernier
est générateur d'inégalité en ce qu'il
n'est ouvert par construction qu'à ceux
qui s'acquittent de l'impôt en question
ce qui n'est pas sans interroger en ce
qui concerne l'article premier de ces de
la proposition
cette VPL s'inscrit au moment où la
forêt française est à la croisée des
chemins comme l'a été l'agriculteur dans
les années 50 nous allons devoir
collectivement prendre des décisions
chronophores je le dis dans les années à
venir il va falloir choisir entre un
modèle industriel d'exploitation des
forêts et un modèle pérenne de civil
culture douce qui respecte la multi
fonctionnalité des forêts
alors que nous avons 16 de parler
décarbonation de notre économie afin de
baisser nos émissions carbone il n'est
pas inutile de rappeler que les arbres
séquestrent et stockent du carbone par
la photosynthèse et libère en retour
l'oxygène en un an un art peut absorber
entre 10 et 20 kg de CO2 mais au-delà de
la fonction écologique c'est aussi la
fonction sociale de la forêt qui doit
être mis en exergue car nos forêts
françaises accueillent chaque année près
de 700 millions de visites
pour protéger ses vecteurs sociaux et
écologiques que sont les forêts il faut
un État fort et présent
or la situation de l'ONF est plutôt le
révélateur du désengagement de l'État en
la matière qui en 20 ans a subi près de
5000 suppressions de poste et il semble
que le mouvement soit bien parti pour
perdre duré car le gouvernement a décidé
l'an dernier de supprimer 500 emplois
supplémentaires sur 5 ans de fait en
2025 l'ONF contrat 8000 fonctionnaires
alors qu'ils étaient 16000 en 1986
ces suppressions sont un non sens car le
dérèglement climatique et le
dépérissement des forêts vont nécessiter
de plus en plus de travail tels que le
suivi sanitaire et le renouvellement des
peuplements forestiers
derrière ces suppressions de postes se
cachent aussi un malaise bien plus
profond et dramatique chez ceux qui par
leur passion entretiennent et protègent
nos forêts entre 2005 et 2020 51 agents
de l'OMF ont mis fin à leurs jours ce
taux est deux fois plus élevé que dans
le reste de la population française
ce malaise est un révélateur de l'état
de la profession et ses suicides ne
peuvent s'expliquer par la seule
solitude du forestier isolé dans les
bois cette profession elle sentiment que
la mutation dont elle fait l'objet
l'alien en ce sens la sémantique est
éloquante le terme de garde forestier a
été remplacé par agent patrimonial à la
base les gages les gardes forestiers
étaient là pour garder la forêt afin de
tout gérer de manière généraliste sur un
territoire donné
désormais l'agent patrimonial est
spécialisé sur le terrain est divisé
branches par branche et soumis à
l'objectif permanent de rendement
c'est précisément cela qui crée une
perte d'identité significative si donc
cette logique comptable qui pousse
éternellement au rendement toujours plus
conséquent et à la financiarisation de
l'exploitation forestière qui est
permise par une ouverture plus grande
aux entités privées dans ce domaine
pourtant commun
pour conclure bien que le sujet ainsi
que le principe qui le sous-tend semble
blond je déplore le manque d'ambition de
la PPL dans la mesure où elle se
cantonne à une part réduite de la forêt
française et n'ayant pour seul mécanisme
la réduction fiscale réduction qui
s'inscrit dans un contexte où le goût
gouvernement regarde perpétuellement la
trission des finances publiques le
désarmement fiscal ne saurait était une
réponse satisfaisante aux limites de
financement des politiques publiques et
ce dans un contexte où elle devrait
investir massivement dans ces plans de
la société pour toutes ces raisons et en
dépit d'une initiative bienvenue avec le
groupe socialiste nous voterons contre